- I’ve got some bad news.
We’re going to practice in a blizzard again even though we play inside.
- You don’t listen, do you?
You ask: Do you have any impressive stats?
All I have are stats.
Megatron always tells me to be like the Lions greats and retire early.
- Ladies and Gentlemen, PAD STATFORD.
- What's the most reliable Ford in Detroit?
A STAF FORD.
- OK, I like dad jokes, and I did not like that!
- Do you wanna know how I got these scars?
- You’re combining Jokers.
- I’ve had a broken back, torn finger ligaments—
My whole career I didn’t know if I existed, but I do.
HAHAHA WE ALMOST BEAT THE CHIEFS!
And other disenfranchised QBs are starting to notice.
Hello, Rodgers…
- AHHH. Oh, I thought it was someone scary like the Bears.
- Hahaha, good joke—
- DON’T YOU LAUGH AT ME, LAFLEUR.
- I used to think the Lions were a tragedy,
but now I realize they’re a comedy.
Can you introduce me as…
- THE CHOKER.
- No, I—
- THE MEDIOCRE.
- THE CAN’T-TAKE-A-JOKER
- Can you guys just let me have one thing?
- HEY, YOU.
YEAH, ALL FREAKIN’ HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF YOU
Flipping listen to me.
I’m P.O.’d about the M.F.ing lurkers watching our B.S.
So subscribe to this G.D. channel or G.T. the Fluff O.
DADDY SAYS SUBSCRIBE.